مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
[موسيقى]
بالسنه الماضيه صارت كتير احداث مهمه
بالنسبه للكراء السعوديه اول حدث كان فوز
المنتخب السعودي على المنتخب الارجنتيني
بكاس العالم 2022 وثاني حدث كان تقريبا
باواخر كاس العالم او بعد نهايه كاس
العالم وهو انتقال رونالدو الى النصر
السعودي وبعد ذلك اجتنا الاخبار عن انتقال
اللاعبين السعوديين الكبار الى الدوري
السعودي وصارت الكره السعوديه جاذبه لنجوم
مثل بنزيما ونيمار وغيرهم من اللاعبين
المميزين ولكن يوم
الثلاثاء شهد حدث مهم جدا ايضا بالنسبه
للكره السعوديه وهو طريقه احتفال
كريستيانو رونالدو امام الشباب البعض ممكن
يقول لي والله يعني الموضوع هو مجرد
احتفال وما بيتعدى ذلك والامور بسيطه يعني
مش محتاجه كل هالتهويل ولكن بحقيقه الامر
انه رونالدو مبارح لما احتفل بشكل او على
طريقه العرضه السعوديه او رقصه العارضه
السعوديه التقليديه عمل حمله تسويق كبيره
جدا لا يمكن لشركات ربما ولا
مسؤولين ولا لحدا انه يقدر يعملها بالشكل
اللازم اولا لانه رونالدو اسم كبير وثانيا
لانه الناس بتقتدي فيه وبتقلده من لاعبين
ومن اطفال وما الى ذلك احتفال رونالدو
بهذه الطريقه امام الشباب له بعدين البعد
الشخصي او الخاص بكريستيانو نفسه واللي
بدل على انه اللاعب سعيد جدا ومبسوط
بالتجربه بالسعوديه يعني شايفين انه روح
ورجعت حتى في كثير كان يعني كلام بالايام
الاخيره عن ان رونالدو اعيد له الشغف
بالسعوديه بعد ما فقدوا مع مانشستر
يونايتد وصار يبين انه هو سعيد انه هو
مهتم انه هو عم يلعب بشغف بعكس ما كان
الامر في انجلترا لذلك احتفاله امبارح
باكد انه رونالدو سعيد رونالدو يعني عم
بصير جزء من هذا المجتمع وهذا المكون
السعودي البعد العام انه كريستي صار منخرط
الى حد ما بالمجتمع بالسعوديه والصفحه
الرسميه لدوري روشن على منصه اكس قالت بعض
المباراه دوري الاوشن طبعا للي ما بيعرفوا
الدوري السعودي المحترفين نشرت الفيديو او
فيديو الاحتفال لرونالدو امام الشباب
وقالت رونالدو اصبح جزءا من ثقافتنا لها
الدرجه الموضوع كبير
فالموضوع انه رونالدو بدا يظهر انه هو صار
جزء من هذا المجتمع جزء من هاي التركيبه
المجتمعيه او الاجتماعيه الموجوده
بالسعوديه وبالتالي هذا امر ايجابي جدا
بالنسبه للاجواء بنادي النصر وايجابي جدا
بالنسبه لرونالدو كشخص وايجابي ايضا جدا
بالنسبه للمشروع العام اللي موجود
بالسعوديه
البعد الاخر اللي لازم نحكي عنه هو البعد
التسويقي لهذا الموضوع كريستيانو رونالدو
لما استقطب الى السعوديه ولما قرر نادي
النصر انه يتعاقد معه كان احد الاهداف
الرئيسيه لهذا التعاقد هو انه رونالدو
يسوق الدوله السعودي لانه رونالدو هو واحد
من اشهر اللاعبين من اكثر الشخصيات على
وجه الارض بل هو اكثر شخص متابعه على وجه
الارض عبر منصه انستجرام وهو شخص مشهور
جدا جدا جدا وبالتالي اي شيء بيعمله ان
كان باحتفالاته اللي بنعرفها كلياتنا ولا
ان كان خارج الملعب والان كان باهدافه
اللي بيسجلها دائما الناس مثل ما حكينا
بتصير تقلده وبالتالي موضوع الاحتفال هذا
راح يخلي قصه العرضه السعوديه هاي محور او
ماده رئيسيه لوسائل الاعلام العالميه
وشفنا كثير تقارير طلعت من يوم الثلاثاء
حتى يوم الاربعاء عن هذه الاحتفاليه او عن
طريقه الاحتفال هذا وبالتالي هذا الامر مش
بس بروج للكره بالسعوديه لا هو بروج
للثقافه السعوديه بيروج لثقافه الشعب
السعودي بروج للامور الى علاقه بالناس
بالمجتمع اكثر ما بيروج بس لانه والله
فكره كره قدم وما الى ذلك بكره ممكن نشوف
لاعبين كبار
وصغار باوروبا وبامريكا الجنوبيه وبغيرها
من دول وقارات العالم عم يقلدوا احتفار
رونالدو لا بل انه من غير المستبعد وشبه
المؤكد انه بكره ممكن نشوف ايضا الاطفال
في الشوارع في الحواري عم تسجل اهداف وعم
تحتفل على طريقه العارضه اللي احتفل فيها
كريستيانو وبالتالي لقطه امبارح كانت لقطه
مهمه جدا لانه شئنا ام ابينا كريستيانو
رونالدو هو الاصل التسويقي الاهم بالنسبه
للدوري السعودي حتى بوجود نيمار بنزيما
كانتي وغيرهم من اللاعبين محرز وغيرهم
يعني لا يمكن ان يقارن احدهم
بالقدره والقوه التسويقيه الهائله
لكريستيانو رونالدو اعتقد انه احتفال
كريستيانو مبارح راح يكون من ضمن
الاحتفالات اللي ما راح تنسى او المشاهد
اللي ما راح تنسى بمسيره كريستيانو مثل
احتفال كالما كالما الاحتفال السيو
الشهيرة ما بعرف كيف كيف
اليوم كريستيانو بيحتفلوا مع جمهور نادي
النصر
واعتقد انه لقطه مبارح كانت لقطه مهمه جدا
ومفصليه بوجود كريستيانو رونالدو مع نادي
النصر هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه بعض الصافي
حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل